i just saw the most
it was the most horrifying clip i've
ever seen on the news
i've seen a lot of ugly things on the
news but in terms of an actual just news
segment not covering an event but an
actual segment
made for a tv show this is the most
horrifying thing i think i've ever seen
a woman goes on a local news show
to debate abortion there's a pro-life
woman there and a pro-abortion woman
there and the pro-abortion woman
took an abortion drug and gave herself
an abortion
live on air
are you advocating stocking up
on abortion pills in case roe versus
wade is overturned
yes so they are incredibly safe safer
than viagra or tylenol
they've actually been in
medical practice since 2000 so if you
order it through the mail that would be
the same thing you would receive if you
were to walk into a clinic
and the change that recently happened is
previously
you had to actually physically go to a
doctor to receive at least the first of
the medication
and now you can get it sent to you
through the mail
uh on a sliding scale
and um
and it is uh extremely easy and uh
private and allows you to really
self-manage your abortion
and charlie i just really i want to
share with you really quickly like
this this year is miss myth pristone
this is the first of two pills you would
take the end of pregnancy and it
wouldn't induce an abortion this very
pill
by blocking the hormone and allowing a
pregnancy to grow and i want to show you
how easy it is and safe it is by taking
it myself
we're going to cut it off there i don't
i don't actually want to show this woman
taking the pill because she's killing
someone on television and this we don't
want to have snuff videos on here so
we're we're not going to show that she
says it's her third abortion
i have no reason not to believe her she
says she's pregnant there i have no
reason not to believe her about that
either she seems giddy to kill her
children and you'll notice when she
holds up the pill
she's got a tattoo on her hand and that
tattoo is
of a pentagram
it's a sign of witches
i'm not this is not some fevered crazy
delusional thinking this is what witches
self-described witches
use as one of their symbols it's a
satanic symbol it's an occult symbol
do you think that's just a coincidence
do you because there are people who say
okay listen you keep your religion you
keep your religion out of my politics
and my health care and then they hold up
their hand and they've got a satanic
symbol there
what about your what about your religion
well let's definitely keep your religion
i think my religion christianity is
pretty good in politics and health care
i think it's good because it's it's a
good rel it's true religion
and it leads to human flourishing
and i think that your religion
satanism is bad and should definitely be
suppressed you we should definitely keep
that one
out of politics and health care
but they will say oh come on you silly
i'm not really a satanist come on
there's nothing there's no there are no
gods there are no deities there's no
angels or demons it's all just stuff i'm
just it's just like kind of a symbol
right a symbol of what darling why are
you wearing the symbol
this reminds me of that quote by
baudelaire the finest trick the devil
ever played was to convince people that
he does not exist
but you see it every once you see it you
can't unsee it
why is this woman why does she have a
satanic symbol on her hand why did saul
alinsky the author of rules for radicals
one of the most influential leftist
organizers and theorists of the last
hundred years
a mentor to hillary clinton why did he
acknowledge in the in the beginning of
his first edition of rules for radicals
why did he acknowledge right after the
dedication lucifer
he in part dedicated the book to lucifer
who he said was the first rebel who lost
himself heaven but one for himself
a political power a kingdom
is that just oh haha it's just a
coincidence it's just a symbol it's not
real well you know i'm seeing a lot of
this stuff
i'm seeing a lot of this symbolism and
and
or symbols are just meaningless
if if what you're saying if what the
materialists are saying is true that
there's nothing spiritual there's
nothing
beyond this physical world of matter
then symbols are meaningless right
because they don't refer to anything
but if they're meaningless why why do we
have them and why are they all kind of
the same symbol and why are they all
why are they all satanic
maybe there maybe there actually is
something there
the question that we need to ask
ourselves in public life is not should
we have religion
in politics or should we not have
religion in politics
all politics comes down to religion
there's no escaping it all human
conflict is theological you can admit it
or you cannot admit it but it's always
going to come down to that because it's
always about moral questions and it's
always about the nature of man and his
relationship to the state and so you
can't avoid it the question is not are
we going to have religion or not have
religion the question is are we going to
have true religion or false religion
which one what do you want do you want
here are two choices that this lady is
going to present to you christianity or
satanism what do you want to live under
well i
i don't know can i just have
zoroastrianism uh maybe i don't think so
i don't think that that's not really an
option is it that's not really what
we're talking about
you can't avoid it
and it's a very childish impulse
of of
people on the left and the right to try
to avoid the ultimately religious
character
of
of politics obviously what that woman
did should be illegal obviously these
drugs should be illegal you're going to
hear some people say well you can't ban
it how can you ban it it's a pill in the
mail you can order it on the internet
i don't know how do we ban other drugs
on the internet how do we order how do
we ban ordering illegal weapons on the
internet how do we ban
downloading child pornography on the
internet how about that should we well
it's on the internet well it's just it's
too hard to control well it's too hard
to ban things
so we're i i don't know we do a pretty
good job of banning all of those other
things we arrest lots of people every
year for violating that law
maybe we can ban this too
certainly you can go after the dealers
certainly you can go after the middlemen
and the distributors certainly you can
go after the mail carriers for goodness
sakes
but you can you can we have political
power guys
we have we just have to use it hey oh
thanks for checking out that clip that's
cool man nice to be with you if you want
more clips
ring the bell subscribe leave a five
star review on apple podcast spot if i
stitch your google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts get it here at
youtube get it at the daily wire get it
on your audio podcast app get it
anywhere you can
to stave off the sensors we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you